Some religious groups require followers to
fast for many hours a day, and continue that
fast for days or weeks!
Isn't not eating for 16 hours a day every
day dangerous?
Bom dia earthlings, thanks for stopping by
DNews, I'm Trace.
The Holy Month of Ramadan is wrapping up this
week, and those Muslims who have been fasting
for 15 hours a day or more will be able to
enjoy food anytime again.
It's not just Muslims who fast, Christians,
Jews, Confucians, Hindus and other religions
have followed the practice for 1000s of years.
Non-religious folks fast too, usually for
medical or dietary reasons.
For some people, the idea of abstaining from
food while the sun is in the sky is unfathomable,
and they might feel that's it's unsafe!
So science is here to demystify some fasting
myths.
A person is considered to be "fasting" if
they've abstained from a meal for 8-12 hours,
so if you think about it, most people fast
every night -- and BREAK their fast in the
morning.
That's where the term BREAK-FAST came from.
Fasting is a completely normal part of being
an animal on the planet earth.
Many organisms eat only once a day or less,
especially those eating high-calorie foods
like meats.
Cold-blooded carnivores, like snakes, can
go DAYS between meals, warm blooded carnivores,
like wolves or coyotes, hunt daily.
Like the coyote, humans are built to be able
to fast for a short period.
A day or so isn't going to hurt you and some
studies have shown short-term fasts can extend
lifespan, boost immunity and mental function,
and so on.
We did a whole video about that last Ramadan.
A study published last month in Cell Stem
Cell found that fasting two to four days at
a time can cause a reduction in white blood
cells, which is actually a GOOD thing.
See, the cells that are killed off are the
older or damaged immune cells, and when the
body rebounds, it uses stem cells to create
brand new, healthy ones.
Long-term fasting, on the other hand, is a
whole other beast.
When humans fast, our bodies go through a
very predictable schedule.
Our bodies are great at squirreling away energy
in the forms of fats and sugars.
But, like coyotes, ideally, we'd eat every
day or so to replenish those reserves.
After 24-48 hours of fasting, the glycogen
reserves stored in our liver and muscles -- basically
carbohydrates -- are empty.
After two days, the body's figured out that
it needs to feed on itself, and will begin
breaking down muscle and fat tissues.
Obviously, water is important too.
72 hours without water is dangerous, so while
straight food fasting isn't so bad for you
in this short a burst, 72 hours is the beginning
of medical dehydration.
So drink water, no matter what.
Some of you might already be Yahoo-ing to
get the lowdown on a fasting diet, but the
problem is, we don't REALLY work that way.
When you fast, you lose a few pounds right
away, but it's mainly liquid weight, and it
will be replaced as soon as you eat again.
Which is another thing, Researchers at Cornell
asked college students to fast for 18 hours,
and then offered them a buffet-style meal
(not unlike Iftar, or community meals after
sundown during Ramadan).
THe most popular foods were those that were
high in calories, carbs and starches, because
our cells don't know if we're EVER GOING TO
EAT AGAIN!
Therefore, they turn on the cravings for carbs
and fats which might fend off long-term starvation.
But that's silly, you know you're going to
eat again!
Don't listen to your reptilian brain!
Ideally, a human coming off of a fast would
eat vegetables and fruits.
Lean meats and a few carbs can be part of
the meal, but not a big part.
Ultimately, fasting puts stress on the systems
of your body, but low-level stress isn't going
to hurt you, and it might build up the systems
-- similar to how exercise stress builds muscles.
Fasting isn't dangerous or deadly, as long
as it's done properly and in partnership with
a healthy diet and exercise.
If you decide to fast, let us know why and
how you've done it!
We're curious.
You can fill us in on your journey in the
comments, or send us a tweet at-DNews or me
at-TraceDominguez.
Speaking of journeys, if you want to know
how MSL Curiosity got to Mars, and what the
heck it's doing up there come to our SpaceOut
on July 30th at 4pm Pacific Time!
We're getting experts from NASA JPL who actually
work with the rover on Mars every sol -- that's
Martian for Day!
See you're learning already!
Get over there and RSVP.
Thanks for watching DNews! and please subscribe.[a]